عوده الرصاص والقذائف الى مناطق واجهه بين
القوات المواليه للرئيس اليمني علي عبد
الله صالح
والمتظاهرين المناوئين له فان المشهد
السياسي اليمني
يشهد ما يبدو من التوصل الى اتفاق سياسي
لانهاء الازمه في البلاد وتزامن ذلك مع
عوده مبعوث الامم المتحده لليمن الى
ام
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين هل تفلح الجهود الامنيه في ضعف
الامل في احياء المبادره الخليجيه
وهل تغير شويه الاطراف على الارض التي
عطلت تنفيذها في الاشهر الماضيه
عشيه جمعه تحمل شعار لا حصانه للقتله
تتكثف الجهود الدبلوماسيه في العاصمه
اليمنيه صنعاء لايجاد مخرج سياسي للازمه
والمفارقه ان هذه الجهود تشتمل على احياء
مبادره خليجيه تتضمن من حصانه للرئيس علي
عبد الله صالح مقابل التنحي ومن شان هذه
المفارقه ان تدلل على حجم التناقضات التي
تعرقل الوصول الى اتفاق
المبادره الخليجيه للمره الرابعه
ولكنها هذه المره في غلاف امميه حركه
مكوكيه على الطريق الجغرافي نيويورك صنعاء
صنعاء الخليج العربي ترمي الى انجاح
مبادره لم تحظى يوما بتوافق جميع الاطراف
وانضم من اخرج نصوصها انها ستمضي الفرقاء
في اليمن وفي ذلك حمل مندوب الامم المتحده
الى اليمن اليات لتنفيذ المبادره تامل
المنظمه الامميه في ان تلقى قبولا ثلاثيا
من المعارضه والشارع والرئيس وتنص هذه
الاليات على المرحله الاولى نقل السلطات
الرئيس للنائب والدعوه لانتخابات رئاسيه
تشكيل حكومه وحده وطنيه تتراسها المعارضه
تشكيل جيش وطني يسبق تاسيس لجنه عسكريه
المرحله الثانيه تبدا من انتخابات الرئاسه
وتستمر عامين تعاد صياغه الدستور في هذه
المرحله الاعداد للانتخابات عامه وبينما
لا يزال الخلاف قائما بين اطراف الازمه
حول هذه الاليات يبشر مجلس التعاون
الخليجي بامكانيه التوقيع على المبادره
الخليجيه هذه المره هذا الحراك السياسي
المتسارع لانهاء الازمه اليمنيه المستمره
منذ عشره اشهر يتناقض مع حضور استقبل به
الشارع المبادره في حلتها الجديده وليس
بعيدا عن السياسه اي ميدانيا ما زالت
ساحات الثوره تمارس اقصى درجات ضبط اذا
عنف لم يتوقف من قبل قوات الرئيس علي صالح
وتحسن الثوره بمعظم فرق الجيش اليمني
المنشقه عن القياده السياسيه لم يكن من
رصاص ما بقي من القوات الحكوميه دائما
للرئيس وهي تشهد على سقوط مزيد من الضحايا
هل هم ضحايا الحل العسكري الذي ربما يروق
لصالح ان تراهم ضحايا مبدا سلميه الثوره
امل 2
ومعنا من الرياض هاني وفاء المحرر السياسي
في صحيفه الرياض وفي الاستديو ينضم الينا
الناشط والباحث اليمني جمال المليكي اهلا
بكما وابدا مع ضيفي من الرياض هل الوفاء
المحرر السياسي في صحيفه الرياض سيد وما
الذي يضمن مهمه جمال بنعمر هذه المره ما
الذي يضمن التوقيع على هذه المبادره بعد
عدد من المرات التي فشل فيها
عمر
انه هو عوده الحركه الموضوع وان كانت
عودته تبشر ان هناك في حلحله من نوع ما في
الموقف اليمني ولكن طبعا هذه الله لا يعني
وجود ضمانات من هذه المره توقع الوطن في
ظل التسريبات التي حصلت في ال بين امس
واليوم بحقوق توقيع المواقف الرياض انه في
مجلس التعاون وما المعارضه اليمنيه قالت
المعارضه ان الاتفاقيه تتوقع
الاليات تنفذ الحريات وقع في الرياض يعني
كلها ما زالت اخبار او تسريبات لا تحمل اي
ضمانات في الوصول الى حل او الى توقيع
نهائي للمبادره الخليجيه اذا
تكمن العقده لانه اثناء ينفذ تقريبا يتكرر
اين المشكله بالتحديد اين يمكن وضع الاصبع
على الجرح
انا في رايي الشخصي انا اعتقد انه ال
الرئيس صالح اه هو الذي في المرات الثلاث
السابقه وهو من تخلف عن توقيع ال اه
المعارضه لاسباب كل مره تختلف عن المره
سبقتها انا اعتقد الرئيس صالح والضمانات
اكثر وضمان سلامه حصانته خطا اذا ما علمنا
انه المطالبات في الشارع اليمني ارتفع من
التنحيه الى الدعوه المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه
باصدار وطلب احضار فبالتالي انا اعتقد ال
الرئيس صالح يريد المزيد من الضمانات حتى
او يريد يعني حتى هناك في اقاويل عن انه
هو يريد مشاركه ابنه احمد في اي حكومه
مستقبليه كونه هو اه امتلك خبره في محاربه
القاعده كما يتحدث
معنا ضيفنا في الاستوديو هنا ثمه من يرى
بان فن المراوغه كما وصفت التي يمارسها
الرئيس علي عبد الله صالح في عدم توقيع
على المبادره التوقيع الفعلي وفي اطلاقه
علنا انه او قوله علنا انه يوافق عليها
انه يريد ويتزامن ذلك مع تصعيد عنف في
الشارع انه يريد تثبيت من بعد الحرب وليس
التنحي بناءا على الضغط من الثوره السلميه
ما رايك هناك امر اه بشكل دائم خلال فتره
الثوره ما ان يتم الحديث عن المبادره او
يتم الحديث عن وصول جمال العمر او غيره او
حتى بعد قرار مجلس الامن الا ويزداد على
عبد الله صالح بالقصف العشوائي هذا له
مجهولين اما ان يكون العالم والاقليم في
الظاهر لصالح وفي الباطن مع علي عبد الله
صالح او ان يكون صالح مستهترا بالعالم
بهذه الصوره يعني لا يستطيع ان افهم انه
بعد قرار 2014
على عبد الله صالح باستهداف
كثير من المدن الى هذه الطريقه اذن سواء
كان التحرير الاول ان تحل الثاني يفترض
هذا على العالم ان يكون اكثر جديه التعامل
مع صالح اللهجه المستخدمه على عبد الله
صالح اليوم لا ترقى مطلقا الى ما يفعله في
الشارع وهذا الذي يسمعه بالمراوغه اكثر من
جمال بن عمر تزيد الطماع
صالح طريقه التعامل واللهجه المستخدمه
تزيد طلع صالح ب اه المراوحه لانها لا
ترقى الى المستوى الذي يستخدم مصالح في
الشارع علي عبد الله صالح ثبت يقينا انه
استخدم المبادره في ترتيب وضع ووضع وفي
اخذ الوقت لقتل الشعب اليمني وكذلك استخدم
الان امام مجلس الامن في اه نفس الانتظار
اه مزيد من التصعيد العسكري
هل توافق سيد جمال على ما قاله ان طريقه
التعامل من قبل المجتمع الدولي مع علي عبد
الله صالح
المهله لديه المزيد من المتظاهرين وتزيد
لديه العنف والطمع برايك
وقت اوسع لانه هو يمارس
ولكن يعني المجتمع الدولي طبيعه المبادرات
السلميه نحن لم نسمع ان تدخل دولي او
القوات الاجنبيه لانه ال المجتمع الدولي
تبني المبادره الخليجيه ال المشكله ليست
في الجهود الدوليه المشكله موجوده داخل
اليمن التوافق بين المعارضه والسلطه هو
المشكله الشارع كل طرف اخر حتى الشارع لا
يعرف الدوله المعارضه المشكله داخل اليمن
نفى بين المعارضه والسلطه المعارضه وافقت
على المبادره ووقعت والرئيس بيقول انه هو
فقد وقع الحزب ولاحقا هو لم يوقع حتى الان
اذن كيف يكون ال الخلاف بين السلطه
والمعارضه
ما قلت له هو الطرف الثالث الشارع لا
يوافق على احيانا على كثير من قرارات
المعارضه
مطالبه الشارع اليمني رغبه في وجود الرئيس
صالح في محاكمه هذه ليست موجوده في
المبادره الخليجيه
ولم توافق عليها المعارضه فبالتالي
المشاريع
المهمه
هنالك جمله في القرار تقول اه ينبغي عدم
الافلات من العقاب وتشكيل لجنه التحقيق
المسؤول عن قتل المدنيين متظاهرين يعني
هذا هذا هنالك عده تفسيرات حول هذه
المساله ولكن المتظاهرون انفسهم يقولون
بان هذه الجمله تفسر على انها
ظاهريا ولكن مواطنين قد تعني مسؤولين على
القتل الفعليين فبالتالي يعني ال
المسؤوليه هنا غير محدد حتى الان في
الشارع اليمني حسب معلومات انهم
بجمع معلومات عن الجرائم التي ارتكبت
والحاق الرئيس صالح فبالتالي المعارض لم
تصل الى هذه النقطه بعد انا اعتقد انه
هناك في اختلاف
الشارع والمعارضه على تنفيذ الاليات هذه
المعارضه ال المبادره الخليجيه على تنحيه
الرئيس صالح وعلى وجود ضمانات لضمان امن
وسلامته نعم اه سيد الملكي الفعل ان
المشكله تكمن في اليه تنفيذ هذه المبادره
ان في كما ذكرت انت في لعبه ما يمارسها
صالح في النهايه ولا يريد هذه المبادره
انه الشارع ليس طرفا ثالثا الشرع والطرف
الاساسي في المعادله باكملها وللاسف
الشديد الخطا الجوهري الكامل في كل
المبادرات انها تتجاهل الشارع والتعامل
الان هناك طرفين سلطه ومعارضه الشارع نحن
نفهم ونقدر
ان السياسه لا تحتمل الخطاب الاخلاقي لكن
من المنطقه السياسي ايضا ان عندما اريد ان
احول اشكاليه معينه الاراء مشاعر الشعوب
لا ينبغي مطلقا ان اتحدث عن ضمانه في ظل
ان هناك نظام سياسي نحن لا نريد ان ندخل
الدولي نريد ان يتعامل مع النظام اليمني
كنظام فاقد للشرعيه اي نظام في اي جديه
السياسي اي اي نظريه
ربما السيد هاني وفا لديه وجهه نظر في
مساله انها هنالك فعلا هو بين الشارع
والاحزاب او المعارضه احزاب اللقاء
المشترك تحديدا لان اللقاء المشترك وافق
على المبادره في المقابل المتظاهرون في
الشارع لن يوافقوا عليها مطالبين بمحاكمه
اه علي صالح هو وابناءه وهذا ان شعار ال
جمعه لاحصانه للقتله والمبادره تنص على
حصانه اذن هناك هذه هي الصوره الجديده
الحادثه اليوم في المجتمع العربي اليوم
اصبح الشارع السياسيه من المعارضه بكافه
اشكالها سواء في اليمن او في اليمن
فالشارع سقفه اليوم اعلى سقف المعارضه
وهذا شيء طبيعي على الشارع ال اه وهذا شيء
طبيعي الشارع ونواصل ضغطه الى ان يتم اه
تحقيق اهداف الثوره الذي من اجلها سقط
الشهداء والذي من اجلها تسعه اشهر صمود اه
يعني لم تشهده اليمن في تاريخها القديم
والحديث اذن نحن امام مشهد اه لم يقرا
بطريقه صحيحه ان هناك شعب قرر بما لا يدع
مجال للشك و بما لا يستطيع ان ناحيه
العوده الى الوراء انه لن يحكمه من يقتله
الاخ يقول ان لا احمد علي الله صالح لديه
في محافظه القاعده احمد علي عبد الله صالح
ان يكون لديه يوما في محافظه الذي خبره
الفين وسته انتخابات
نفسه وقد
من ال ولهذا ربما اختاروا هذه المبادره
ودعم يعني الحل السلمي والتوجه الى عبد
الله صالح بالتوقيع على هذه المبادره سيده
هناك فعلا من يقول بان بعض الدول اه
وبالتحديد الدول الخليجيه ايضا بهذه
المبادره قدم التوقع علي عبد الله صالح
ما يريده الشعب
عندما مبادره لم تقدمها للرئيس صالحه
قدمتها اليمن للشعب اليمني ما يهم دول
الخليج مصلحه الشعب اليمني الحديث مسافه
واحده من جميع فئات الشعب اليمني فريق على
اخر هي تريد ان يستقر الوضع في اليمن ان
يعيش اليمن ازدهارا اكثر من الله عليه ان
تهدا الازمه هذه التي طالع مدها دون اي
فعاليه وبالتالي دول الخليج لم تقدم
المبادره من اجل انقاذ الرئيس صالح والا
كان الرسول الحلقه عليها منذ اليوم الاول
هي وقاطعه لحقن الدماء في اليمن من اجل
استقرار نحن نعلم جميعا من الشارع اليمني
الان يعاني سياسيه اجتماعيه اقتصاديه كل
هذه معاناه وطالت ولكن المبادره هي من اجل
اليمن ككل وليس من اجل النظام اليمني
استطلاع افضل المواقف الداخليه المرتبه
المرتقبه لزياره الامم المتحده ابقوا معنا
لمناقشه هذا المحور ولكن بعد فاصل قصير
اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقاتنا التي تتناول
ما يبدو اقترابا من التوصل الى اتفاق
سياسي لانهاء الازمه في اليمن اعود وارحب
بضيفي اه سيد جمال الملك ضيفي في
الاستوديو
وقعت مبادره لم توقع وقعت لم توقع جمال
عمار يذهب الى صنعاء يعود من صنعاء يذهب
الى الرياض ثم يعود الى صنعاء ثم يعود الى
مجلس الامن الى الامم المتحده
بالاخر هناك خلاف على اليه التنفيذ حيث
تحولت هذه المبادره التي كان من المفترض
ان تحل المشكله الى مشكله بحد ذاتها هي
بالفعل اصبحت اه مشكله ونحن نطالب الخليج
ولا نطالب العالم ان يقفوا او الحاجه الى
الشعب اليمني يريدهم ان يقولوا للبلاد ان
تجد ويعرفوا ان الضحيه بحاجه الى مناصره
لا نريدهم ان ينحرف الشباب
النقطه الثانيه ان المبادره هناك من يشكك
في كانها لصالح ان الذي طلبها وعد عبد
الله صالح اولا اقول لك باختصار ما هي
المبادره التي يمكن ان تكون مقبوله بناء
على قراءه صحيحه لما يحدث في الميدان
بتجاهل ما يحدث في في الميدان لن تكون اي
مبادره ناجحه لانها ستكون متجاوزه للفاعل
الاساسي في الشارع اي مبادره لا تحمل
الواحد رحيل صالح وعدم تدخل في مستقبل
اليمن باي شكل اشكال التدخل انه يكفي انه
اساء الماضي والحاضر فلن يقبل اليمني
منحوته وشهرته ان يتحكم صالح الذي ثبت انه
يقتل افراد الشعب لمستقبل النقطه الثانيه
ان عائله صالح وحاشيته عليها ان تذهب من
المشهد ان يتحمل هموم نقطه لكل هذه النقاط
الجمال عفوا هذه النقاط والمبادره اخرى
بتقول يجب على هذه المبادره ان تكون على
هذه الشاكله اذا لم تستطع اقناع الناس الى
الشارع وهم اللقاء المشترك المتطرف
الاحزاب المعارضه كيف تصنع بها ال ال
الدول الخليجيه او الدول الاخرى الداخله
على خط ال المصالحه هنا او لتسويه الازمه
ولا تقنع من
بناء الفتح لنقطه ال ال ال ال المبادره
علينا ان نتكلم عن الملامح المبادره
المطلوبه المقبوله التي ستكون مقبوله ربما
لدى الشارع النقطه الثالثه هي موضوع هيكله
الجيش ب ما يجعله جيش للشعب وليس جيش
العائله هذه الثلاث النقاط الاساسيه التي
هي رحيل الا تجد انها كانت يعني هذا يعني
بحسب السياسه فان الممكن كان هذا هذا اقصى
ما
حضر على التوصل اليه مع الاخذ بالاعتبار
ان هناك شارع اخر يتظاهر ما علي عبد الله
صالح ومع الاقبال اعتبار علي عبد الله
صالح نفسه وما يمكن ان يمارسه ومع الاخ
بالاعتبار ايضا مصالح الدول القريبه من
اليمن هذا ليس ليس ليس صحيحا دليل على ذلك
انه ليس هناك شارع مقابل شارع مطلقا والكل
يعرف وعدسات الاول العالم تطور على الارض
الميدان القوى من ميزان القوى اكثر من
ثمانيه اشهر تسعه اشهر على الثوره السلميه
على المطالبات لم يتزحزح علي عبد الله
صالح ذهب الى الرياض وعاد الى اليوم
السياسي
يمكن اعتبارها حل وسط ممكن اولا النظام
السياسي رئيس عصابه ان يسلم له بانه
الاقوى ايضا اكتسب شرعيه الشرعيه السياسيه
انه قضيه
تتحدث مثاليه لو اردنا التحدث بواقعيه ان
اتحدث بالواقعيه وعلميه ان اي سياسي في
العالم لا يكتب الشرعيه من القوه ويكتب
الشرعيه من من طواعيه الشارع له ومن
السيطره الجغرافيه ومن التمثيل الدبلوماسي
الحالي علي عبد الله صالح في هذه الثلاثه
النقاط فقط المفقود الذي وبالتالي لا
ينبغي المطلقه انا اتكلم الا على عبد الله
صالح لديه القوه يعني انا م نحو شرعيه وا
منحه في الشارع هذا منطق لا لا تحتمله
السياسه اصلا اي نظام يقتل شعب هذا النظام
فاقد للشرعيه على العالم وعلى الاقليم ان
يتعامل مع نظام فاقد للشرعيه ان الحقيقه
ان يبحثوا على المخرج ان كانت له صداقات
لكن ليس من حقها الثوره من اجلها شعب لمده
تسعه اشهر صدقت من اجلها الاف الشهداء
وسقط عشرات الالاف من الجرحى لا يمكن باي
حال من الاحوال ان يقبل المواطن اليمني
شهاده وكرامته ان يحكموا واضح التنبيه بان
يقتله هذا لن يكون اذا لم يدرك العالم هذه
النقطه لن يكون هناك حل سيد هاني وفا من
الرياض
لدى اه او توجه تهما الى الدول الخليجيه
التي تقف وراء هذه المبادره بانها لا تقطع
بما يكفي على على عبد الله صالح ولا تدعم
بما يكفي لاراده الشعب المتظاهر والدليل
على ذلك ربما ما قاله اليوم السفير
البريطاني في اليمن ام كان واضحا جدا قال
ان الوقت حان كي ينقذ الصالح تعهده بترك
السلطه اننا نحتاج الى افعال اكثر من
اقوال اجل اكمال العمليه الى اللواء متقدم
على الدول الخليجيه في ال الضغط على عليه
عبد الله صالح ما رايك
يجب ان الامور
يعني اذا كان هناك مبادره اخرى سواء دوليه
واقليميه لماذا لم تكن على الطاوله لا
يوجد على الطاوله حتى بالنسبه الامم
المتحده غير المبادره الخليجيه هي في
المبادره مقنعه مبادره ممكن ان ترضي جميع
الاطراف على المشكله
الطرف الرئيس الاكبر يعني انت
لاشعار الجمعه هذا عدا عن الجماعات
الاخريات التي تظاهروا فيها وهي المبادره
مع احترامي للشارع اليمني واعجاب الطويل
وعدم اللجوء الى استخدام القوه
اه لكن ال ال الشعب اليمني اذا كان يعني
في التفاوض على هذه المبادره المحول
بالتفاوض بين السلطه والمعارضه
الشارع اليمني اذا كان له من كلمه فهو
سيقول عبر المعارضه يعني لا يوجد ممثل
الشارع اليمني في المفاوضات المفاوضات بين
السلطه والمعارضه برعايه الامم المتحده
ودول مجلس التعاون
وبالتالي اذا كان هناك من اراء او من
اعتراضات الشارع اليمني على المبادره
الخليجيه فانا اعتقد السبيل الوحيد
لايصالها لطاوله المفاوضات
هو عبر حزب المعارضه واحزاب المعارضه
وفعلا الخارجيه السعودي فيلتقي وحدتنا
المعارضه برايك ما توقعات او ما المنشوده
على هذا اللقاء
وبالتاكيد المملكه يعني دائما ما كانت
ويعني
وراء استقرار اليوم ان تتمنى التكرار لم
تدعم الى من المملكه من ان من اكبر ولكن
اكبر الدول الداعمه لليمن الى حدودنا
مشترك متداخلين اجتماعيا واقتصاديا اعتقد
انه ال من مصلحه المملكه استقرار اليمن
فبالتالي ال ال يكون هناك في وفد من
المعارضه جاء الى الرياض الخبر هذا اسمع
منك انا واجتمعوا بس مون انا اعتقد بدون ا
نادره الاجتماع ولكن انا متاكد تمام
التاكيد ان هذا الاجتماع سيكون في مصلحه
الامام بشكل عام وليس
كما يعني المعارضه او الاخر يعني يقول ان
المبادره الخليجيه من اجل ال ال الرئيس
صالح ولكن هي من اجل اليمن تقول سيد جمال
المليكي
كما راي السيد هاني وفا السعوديه ودول
الخليج لا تريد مصلحه اليمن وتفاوض الحزب
وليس الشارع
ينفع اي مفاوضه مع ال الاحزاب وفي النهايه
الشارع هو من يتظاهر ويخاطر بحياته ويبقى
خلال اشهر في البرد وفي الحرب اولا
المعارضه محوره للنقاش عن الشعب اليمني
اذا حققت اهدافه اذا لم تحقق اهداف الثوره
فهي مباشره لا تعتبر محوله من الشعب
اليمني مطلقا وبالتالي على المعارضه ان
تدرك هذه النقطه انها ان لم تعمل على
تحقيق اهداف الشارع وا هدف الشارع فقط سوف
لن تكون ممثله وست تجاوزها الشارع كما
تجاوز ال اه كما تجاوز اه الشارع العربي
في دول اخرى وبالتالي علينا ان ندرك بغض
النظر عن تفاصيلها السعوديه مع او
والتاريخ في هناك تفاصيل كثيره ولو قدر
كلام الاخ اه كسياسي لكن اه و او كمثقف
لكن النظام السياسي مختلف تماما عن هذه
الصوره المثاليه التي ربما يصورها الاخر
انا اعتقد انه الى الموضوع
واصبح واضحا للجميع ان على من بعض
الخليجيه اصبح عليها ان اخلاقي ضد الشعب
اليمني هذا الارث لا يسقط الاب موقف اكثر
وضوحا يا اختي لا معنى انه لم يصرح ولا
مسؤول سعودي عن كل ال على المحرقه على
سبيل المثال على بينما قامت الدنيا ولم
تقعد في السعوديه عندما في القصر الرئاسي
والكل يعرف ان الى الداخل
الرجل
يعني ما هذه ربما ملاحظه في مكانها لم
نسمع مسؤولا سعوديا واحدا
كما قال ضيفي الان
لو سمحت
اعطي مثال هناك حواجز كثيره والمتظاهرون
على الارض كانوا هنالك يعني تبرم من
الموقف السعودي اشار اليها اكثر من مره
اذن كيف تقيم هنا الوساطه انكن ان لم تكن
تعجب الشارع
هي الوساطه الخليجيه وليست السعوديه
المملكه ضمن الوساطه الخليجيه فبالتالي
انا اعتقد انه مواقف المملكه السابقه
والحاليه اعتقد تعبر بشكل واضح وصريح عن
مدى احترام وموده رغبه في مصلحه اليمن في
المنطقه العربيه
هذا السؤال لم يتبق الكثير من الوقت اه
جمال بنعمر الان ياتي الى صنعاء وقد اتى
وذهب وعاد كذا مره وفي كل مره كانت الفشل
الحالي حليفه للاسف هذه المره برايك هل
يغامر وياتي ان كان مره اخرى
وانا اعتقد ان الامم المتحده امام حقيقي
ومختبر حقيقي لانه لم يعد هناك حاجه
للتاكد ان علي عبد الله صالح من بعد قرار
2014 الى اليوم الى هذه اللحظه و شوارع
ومدن وقرى السكنيه تقصف الى هذه اللحظه
الذي يحدث فيها قبل ان اطلع للسيد
العمر اذا الامم المتحده امام اختبار
حقيقي هل فعلا تريد الاستقرار لليمن في ظل
اه شخص اما انه يستهدف العالم بهذه
الطريقه او انه بتعاون مع العالم في قصف
الشعب على العالم ان يحدد الحقيقه
ان يكون عادله ان يقول لجلال ويتعامل مع
النظام اليمني على انه
للمبادره برايك كنت قد سالتك السؤال ولم
تجمعنا في سياق الحلقه قلت لك هل المشكله
في اليه التنفيذ ان في ان صالح لا يريدها
اصلا برايك باختصار على عبد الله صالح لا
يريد المبادره الخليجيه
اه لانه اه
بافضل منها هذه النقطه النقطه الاخيره
الامان المشكله الاساسيه هي في عدم قراءه
الفاعل الاساسي الذي هو الشارع لم يراعي
الشارع عدم مراعاه الشارع تقف عائقا امام
اي مبادره شكرا جزيلا لك الناس والبحث
اليمني جمال المليكي ايضا اشكر ضيفي من
الرياض هاني وفا المحرر السياسي في صحيفه
الرياض و
اشكركم مشاهدين او بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر غدا باذن الله
قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
اللقاء
ام